[Musik]
dreist dreister am 30 oder auch dumm
dümmer am dümmsten so oder so ähnlich
könnte man die protagonisten dieser
geschichte bezeichnen dieser passat grad
am montagabend in berlin gegen eine
laterne in dem wagen zwei männer eine
frau und zwei kleine kinder im alter von
zwei und sieben jahren so weit so
schlimm aber es kommt noch schlimmer
denn alle insassen außer der kinder
waren komplett sternhagelvoll schwer
alkoholisiert der fahrer hier im grauen
shirt hatte sage und schreibe 1,9
promille
fassbar das jüngste kind saß
unangeschnallt auf dem schoß der mutter
dass niemand verletzt wurde ein wunder
es kommt aber noch wilder
augenzeugenberichten die kurz nach dem
crash dieser silberne audi etwas weiter
entfernt von der unfallstelle parkte der
fahrer hier im weißen poloshirt zur
tankstelle lief und noch mehr bier
besorgte um das anti unfall truppe
auszuteilen vermutlich also ein
bekannter es sollte munter weiter
getrunken werden alles unter den augen
der angerückten polizei unglaublich aber
wahr das ende der geschichte der fahrer
wurde festgenommen in der bier lieferant
kam wieder frei und zu hoffen bleibt nur
dass alle beteiligten aus dieser
unfassbaren dummheit ihre lehren ziehen
[Musik]